I've always secretly wanted to be a
machine I felt like if I was a machine
I'd never let things fall through the
cracks I wouldn't forget things and I do
everything I needed to do on time every
time I knew there were people out there
that were like this and I wanted to know
what makes them tick
so a few years ago I started a
newsletter called super organizers where
I profiled 50 of the top performers in a
variety of fields I've talked to
managers who track everything they do in
a day in 15-minute increments I've
talked to investors who keep
spreadsheets of every single person
they've ever met I've talked to CEOs who
keep their calendars basically empty and
rarely ever do meetings like ever I've
also experimented with a lot of hacks
myself to try to get me closer to my
ideal I've taped my mouse shut while I'm
sleeping and stared at a sun lamp to
increase my energy levels I visualize my
compassionate self and tried all sorts
of supplements to hack my body chemistry
sometimes the things I try work and
sometimes they don't sometimes they're
just kind of ridiculous but I want to
share with you the best trick I've
learned in all of my exploring the ideal
of being a machine is actually a trap it
gets in the way of our productivity
because it makes us blind to the roots
of our actual problems we are not
machines we're emotional beings and
learning to skillfully recognize and
work with our emotions is the only way
to actually be productive day to day yo
shame fear so often they're at the base
of what's going on for us in ways that
we barely understand what's underneath
our productivity problems isn't just the
need for a new tool or system but
something going on in our emotional
lives and being aware of and observing
how our emotions can affect us can open
up a lot of flexibility and freedom to
make progress when we'd otherwise be
stuck I found that the most productive
people in the world you know the ones
who are most machine-like actually
recognize this and they often do three
things to work with it they're aware
when they have a problem they observe
what's going on without judgment so that
they can understand it and they keep
experimenting with systems or teens
mindsets and tools until it changes this
might sound simple and it is but it's
actually very hard to do because at each
stage we get blocked and twisted up by
the shame you'll fear and doubt the
things that get in the way of seeing
things clearly to do this well requires
a level of emotional Mastery that is
very difficult to practice so let me
walk you through it and show you how it
can work awareness is the first step
that means being aware of problems in
your productivity but that's harder than
it seems no matter no matter what the
issue is it's much easier to ignore it
and hope that it goes away than to admit
that something's wrong we feel like we
should be able to just do better we feel
like well that's the job I should just
suck it up whatever the problems that
you're encountering in your productivity
you might not think about them that
often because it's pretty painful but
there's magic in becoming aware of the
problems that we're ordinarily not aware
of
the most productive people have regular
practices that they use to maintain that
awareness sometimes it's journaling
sometimes it's mindfulness sometimes
it's just a walk sometimes it's therapy
but everyone has something here's an
example from my own life I have a ton of
trouble staying on top of my inbox I'm
the CEO of a startup and so this is
really hard for me to admit it first it
seemed like an indictment of me and my
ability to be successful if my inbox was
a mess but last year after a lot of
reflection as I realized that I had to
face the fact that the backlog was
causing problems throughout my company
once I was aware of the problem I could
start the next step observation when I
moved into the observation stage I
wanted to see with as little judgment as
possible what usually leads to my inbox
being crowded
observing without judgment was really
difficult for me my sense of doubt and
fear came up I thought should I really
need to do this I really felt like I
should just be able to get through my
inbox without any problems but once I
got beneath that I began to notice
something really surprising there were
actually many periods where I was on top
of my inbox it's just said every couple
weeks there would be a shift or just
turned into a giant mess
and it had a very specific trigger
either a single email that I really
didn't want to deal with or a really
busy period in my life where I couldn't
look on my inbox for a day or two and
when this happened emails would start to
pile up and I'd start to feel shame I'd
avoid my inbox and the pile would just
get way worse it was a vicious cycle
once I saw this I realized that there
was a logical place to intervene what I
really needed to do was to catch myself
right at the point every couple weeks
where my clean inbox was turning into a
mess and if I could do that I knew I
could keep it clean the rest of the time
this brings us to The Next Step
experimentation once productive people
have recognized a problem and observed
its Contours without judgment
they try new solutions to find out what
works again this can be really easy to
get twisted up about we're all filled
with preconceptions about what's in and
out of bounds to experiment with and
we're really Boxed In by those
preconceptions we don't want to look
silly we don't want to look weak but if
we allow ourselves to find what works
for us we often find things that no one
else would for me I tried a lot of
different experiments to deal with my
inbox problems I tried going to a new
coffee shop every time I needed to power
through some emails so I tried talking
about it with my business partner and
other people at my company to try to
lower my sense of Shame about it I tried
a one-touch email strategy I tried only
checking my email twice a day but none
of these really solve the problem
completely
so I kept going and I had a big Insight
I figured out that I might be able to
use my own desire not to let people down
to help me get through my inbox I'm
lucky enough to split a virtual
assistant with my business partner so I
wondered what if I put an hour on my
calendar a few times a week where they
would babysit me at the beginning of the
hour they'd message me and ask me how
many emails I had in my inbox and at the
end of the hour they'd message me again
to ask how many I had gotten done
I use my virtual assistant but you can
use anyone in your life a family member
or friend who struggles with something
similar and propose a trade it literally
takes a couple seconds to message back
and forth when I started to consider
this my immediate reaction was shame I
felt like I should not need a babysitter
to do my work and I dreaded the
conversation where I had to ask for this
kind of thing I also dreaded admitting
it to anyone else it all seemed very
very silly
but I decided to try it anyway and turns
out just that little interaction a few
times a week makes a gigantic difference
for me getting a message from my
assistant keeps me on task on my email
and prevents the piles from being
created which makes it really easy for
me to keep my inbox clean at every other
time
and now I'm sitting here almost a year
later with a clean inbox on a consistent
basis this may not work for you but it
does work for me you might find that
other approaches are better like
transferring your emails to your to-do
list or making sure you're following a
one-touch inbox strategy or maybe even
examining why you need to get through
your inbox in the first place but the
only way to find that out is to try it
what I've realized in all of my
exploring is that I actually didn't
really ever want to be a machine I just
felt guilty and ashamed for not being
one
and once I started to work with that
everything changed for me we think
productivity is about software and
notebooks and to-do lists and Frameworks
and calendars and schedules and inboxes
and it is all of those things but it's
also about our brains and our bodies
it's about our emotions and how they
guide us and sometimes get in our way if
you turn over the rock of productivity
you can find a lot hiding underneath
identifying what's there is the best
productivity hack I know